October the 3rd on the turkey Bulgaria
border and someone is about to get shot
19 year old Syrian refugee Abdullah
falls to the floor
the bullet has gone through his hand and
into his chest
this is a remote area other migrants do
what they can to save his life
Abdullah claims he was shot by Bulgarian
border officials after they caught his
group illegally entering Bulgaria and
pushed them back to Turkey
is
the refugees say officials first fired
into the air they threw Stones claiming
Bulgarian officers searched the women in
the group in a sexual manner
the Bulgarian government says the stones
caused this damage that the group burned
objects and was hostile and aggressive
and an officer was injured
they say no shots were fired from their
side
but Abdullah says Bulgarian border
forces are frequently violent
um
Bulgaria is part of the EU and the
shooting happened here on the border
with turkey the surroundings in the
video help us pinpoint the location we
can match up this tree and the Border
fence in the background it's hard to
prove who took the shot as well as the
refugees we know the Border force was
there earlier footage shows a military
truck and Land Rover Discovery often
used by them and here you can see
officials in dark uniforms the Border
forces were dark green
expert sound analysis of the shot
suggests it was fired from a small
firearm around 30 meters from the person
filming that person was facing the
Bulgarian border
illegal migration is a massive problem
for Bulgaria and this route from Turkey
is the most popular this year alone more
than 14
000 people have been detained for
entering without permission
Bulgaria is used as a gateway to Europe
but a surge in illegal immigrations
raised concerns about people being
unlawfully pushed back the UN warning of
a disturbing pattern of threats
intimidation and violence on the eu's
Central and Southeastern borders
we traveled to the border near where
Abdullah was shot to find out more it
didn't take long to see signs of Asylum
Seekers
as you get closer to the Border there's
clear evidence of the vast number of
people using this route to Cross so here
is a rest area with food Syrian snacks
clothes where people have taken a break
before the long journey ahead
then a few kilometers from Bulgaria we
stumble upon a terrified group of
syrians fleeing the war
after gaining their trust they tell me
their stories a 15 year old shows me
scars he says he got from being beaten
by Bulgarian authorities on a failed
Crossing this is his eighth attempt
one time Bulgarian police arrested US
and started hitting us he tells me they
set dogs on us and sent us back just
wearing shorts two weeks ago he saw
someone shot in the leg
others in the group talk a systematic
abuse
foreign
are you frightened that if you get
caught again
[Music]
and that's the reality fleeing War at
home most will risk beatings abroad
the Bulgarian government denies the
allegations saying it follows
International and domestic laws adding
aggression against border officials is
increasing
but the accusations are disturbing
threats violence and intimidation
routinely wielded on the edge of Europe
Siobhan Robbins Sky News on the
Bulgarian border